hey guys this is andrew from
tradingsensors.com so i've been working
as a professional trader for the past
six years in hong kong and right now
guys i'm doing youtube videos because i
want to actually show you what kind of
tools and techniques i like to use and
how to use them
what is working what is not what is
actually the most efficient to make
money on the market
so if you want to know about all the
stuff and how to use it
you are in the right place so today i
want to make an update on
clvs clovis let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so for those who are
actually watching my other videos you
can see that i do
regular updates for the past two three
months on
clovis because guys this stock is in a
perfect situation for me
to lift off so we had here
just break out so i'm going to show you
quickly what i did
so we're going to do some technical
analysis guys this is what i do every
day
for the past six years now i mostly
learn everything by myself on the field
by losing money by making money and i
know
what to use and how to associate the
different
indicators between them and how to set
up nice
profitable trades this is what uh i'm
good at so
here we have this download sloping
trendline so guys this
we can have a lot of discussions here uh
but how to do this one all right
you can make it like this you can make
it like this i i do it like this because
for me the recent past is the most
important
uh some other traders are gonna tell you
no i don't need i don't do
this one like this whatever everyone
then they're gonna do things differently
from me and maybe in the end we all
gonna make money i don't know
what i can tell you is that what i'm
showing you guys is working in my
environment
i build my framework in which i'm
comfortable to trade
and in my framework this is my
resistance level that has been broken
and then retested
and here we had almost a fake breakout
this is not to break out once again guys
to have a proper breakout you need to
have
two consecutive candles in the time
frame you're training so here on the
daily time frame
that are below your support level in
this case here we had
just we just one all right it's closed
here
so true but it didn't confirm so the
breakout has not been confirmed and even
if it was guys i was telling you that
above 450 i'm still a buyer because i
have this support level
same thing i connected the recent flows
that are here that is going higher so
this is nice because you know it's an
exit level
this is my safety line below 450 guys
i reconsider everything i know that you
know we have some news i checked the
news on yahoo finance today there is
nothing uh you know particular
so if we go below this i know that this
pharmaceutical firm
probably have some issues with i don't
know what and then
uh you know the flows are telling me
it's time to exit
for now the flows are telling me it's
time to enter so
uh once again we have this breakout that
has been tested here
so i was telling you guys i'm a buyer at
530 550
uh careful like below five and below 450
but you know actually this whole area
and i've been saying this for a long
time is a very nice area to buy
here we have a quite bullish move ten
percent up um
on um tuesday's session and i expect
guys a very strong move up to come
all uh i'm not scared to tell you this
is the perfect situation to trade
as most of the videos i'm publishing
guys on my youtube channel i'm giving
you
uh the nice uh actually trades i'm also
doing some videos you know on some more
you know interesting and bigger stocks
like tesla where you have sometimes
corrections but all the
smaller stocks that i i do it's usually
because there is a very nice situation
so don't forget to uh click the sub and
like button
so you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new guys so
here like i said i think we are going to
go
higher and the question is what is the
short interest because the bigger the
short interest the more likely a short
quiz
is to happen so you go on the market
watch guys
uh you type your ticker clbs
it's here and you check the short
interest oh 35
guys that's a lot all right updated on
the 26th of february every two weeks
guys
once again if i see that this data is
different from bloomberg i'll let you
know but i'm not allowed to show you
bloomberg here
and i cross check on market bit you can
do this i mean i crosstrack even with
bloomberg but you guys
don't have bloomberg so go on market
beat and market watch and check it
yourself and don't believe anyone
that is telling you that i don't know
what is the biggest short in the market
like gme and amc
and that the data that is published is
wrong guys this is [ __ ] all right
the data is correct those firms are
listed they cannot lie i mean if they do
they're going to have some issues with
the regulator and the controls are
very strong on all those firms and here
32
so the data is similar so it's correct
uh sometimes is wrong i saw that for
example the market watched the data was
wrong for
quite a while on amc so here 35
so guys if the price action is going
above 12
all right so we have time but trust me
that this is gonna be a level
where the hedge funds are gonna start to
uh cut the positions
and if this happened guys here i'm nice
it's gonna be something like this well
maybe i'm a bit exaggerating here
you know because this is too much
this is four thousand percent but guys
it's possible all right
it's possible look where we're coming
from but the fundamentals are going to
be important too
so you know technicals are good to enter
a trade but
you know to be sustainable a sustainable
rally only occurs when the firms is
actually doing better and when there are
some changes in the business model or
whatever
but we could easily go back to 100 guys
so make a
very very nice upside move
and what can you lose here if you buy at
five you buy here guys you stop loss
here
so all right you can lose 25 percent you
stop loss at full
you know here i'm at like uh yeah even
four
390 whatever so you can lose 25 percent
and you can make like i said
1 000 so guys the risk would ratio is
beautiful
and it's a very very nice situation
to enter this trade so that's it for me
i hope you guys enjoyed this video
and if you did please don't forget to
click the sub like and bell button so
you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to show i see you guys